[Music]
i'm karen
um i live in melbourne in australia in
2017 my husband and i
um were going to start trying for a
second baby
sadly in june of that year we lost our
daughter to stillbirth so
yeah emotional baggage and weight
baggage was still lingering for quite
some time and the grieving process can
take
you know a lifetime quite honestly the
better health challenge was
something that was in everyone's minds
and on all the conversations and i
figured well what a great opportunity to
just have a bit of support um and not be
doing it all by myself
and you know have some people cheer me
on that that moment of
looking at my own before photo and going
no i don't want this for me anymore
so i started doing the keto challenge
the kilos started to get you know drop
off which was really nice
and um yeah it was just you know a good
thing to
to actually feel like i wasn't hungry
all the time
and i wasn't you know using
chocolate as a emotional crutch because
i knew i had a reason to
not do that anymore when i did my
initial weigh-in at the beginning of the
challenge i was
just under i think it was 90.9 kilograms
and i actually
got on the scales yesterday down i'm in
the 79
range now kilograms on my wedding day i
was about 83
83 and a half kilos so i'm actually
lighter than i was when i got married
in 2012 so that's a really nice feeling
too
now as two kids later and lots of lots
of life events that have gone on and
um yeah so that's just life sometimes
you know brings on extra kilograms i
guess
but um they don't need to stay there so
yeah doing that doing the challenge has
been really great to actually just
motivate me to keep going
i see the after photo and i'm like
there's a big
difference there and i can see and i can
feel the difference
you